Розмірковуючи про майбутнє США з новообраним президентом Джо Байденом та ймовірну зовнішню політику демократа,
німецька преса особливу увагу присвячує подальшій долі "Північного потоку-2".
Таблоїд "Більд" навіть прямим текстом заявляє: "Джо Байден хоче назавжди зупинити Путінів "Північний потік-2"".
Видання посилається на грізні заяви команди Байдена.
Досі багато хто у Німеччині пов'язував санкції проти учасників газогону виключно із Дональдом Трампом,
очікуючи, що зі зміною керівника Білого дому напруга між Європою і США через суперечливий проєкт спаде.
Однак не так сталося, як гадалося. У команді Байдена повідомили, що розширять список санкцій вже в січні,
ймовірно, одразу після його вступу на посаду президента. Під штрафні заходи нібито потраплять фактично всі,
хто має хоч якийсь стосунок до реалізації проєкту: від підрядників до страхових компаній.
Офіційний Берлін тим часом намагається розблокувати реалізацію "Північного потоку-2"
і днями ще раз озвучив свою позицію щодо санкцій США:
Ми вважаємо ці так звані екстериторіальні санкції порушенням міжнародного права. Це в першу чергу.
Але і те, що відбувалося паралельно з цим процесом, що три американських сенатори написали листа до Засніца,
де були не лише юридичні висновки, але й, якщо почитати, неприховані погрози, - це політично неприйнятно.
Саме у німецькому портовому містечку Засніц зберігаються труби для будівництва
останнього відрізка "Північного потоку-2".
Від ідеї запровадити санкції проти німецьких відомств, які дозволили будівництво, в США врешті відмовились.
Однак на серйозні зрушення розраховувати не варто, вважає багато експертів.
Під час президентства Байдена Вашингтон буде намагатися вести з Берліном більш цивілізовану дискусію
щодо "Північного потоку-2". Навіть якщо позиція Берліна в цьому питанні залишиться тією ж.
Те, що тон зміниться, є очікуваним. Однак водночас, якщо сформулювати коротко:
ні, не думаю, що за Байдена позиція США щодо "Північного потоку-2" справді якось зміниться.
Російсько-європейський газопровід Байден ще у 2016 році називав "фундаментально поганою угодою".
Днями ж його команда заявила про незмінність цієї позиції. Вже після виборів демократи й республіканці у Конгресі
домовилися про досі найсуворіші санкції проти учасників проєкту "Північний потік-2".
Щодо нищівної критики "Північного потоку-2" - це була позиція не лише адміністрації Трампа, а насамперед Конгресу США.
Саме Конгрес запровадив санкції. Він запровадить у грудні подальші санкції.
В цьому питанні ми побачимо послідовність.
Критика США щодо "Північного потоку-2" не зменшиться, а радше збільшиться.
І адміністрація Байдена ніяк не змінить цей підхід.
У глобальному контексті стане спокійніше, але не робіть помилкових висновків.
Американці все ще мисляться по-трампівськи - "Америка передусім".
Ви цього не почуєте від Байдена, але він буде протискати цю позицію.
Укладку труб "Північного потоку-2" планували завершити наприкінці 2019 року. Однак рік тому, в грудні 2019-го,
будівництво призупинили через санкції США проти компаній-трубовкладальниць.
Нині ж, упродовж кількох місяців Вашингтон планує ухвалити нові доповнення до проєкту оборонного бюджету.
Вони дозволять запроваджувати санкції проти компаній, які могли б надавати "Північному потоку-2"
послуги зі страхування й сертифікації - захід, який вже обговорювали в США, але ще не задіяли.
І судячи з усього, у Берліна не так вже й багато інструментів, аби протидіяти намірам Вашингтона.
Можна було б оскаржити це рішення в Міжнародному суді, така можливість є, але цей процес затягнеться надовго,
і рішення суду передбачити буде складно. Можна було б запровадити санкції у відповідь.
Це міг би зробити Євросоюз, однак це малоймовірно, адже в Євросоюзі погляди на цей проєкт досить сильно різняться.
Німеччина могла б також запровадити двосторонні санкції стосовно США.
Але знову ж таки - не думаю, що Берлін піде цим шляхом. Оскільки в такому разі США можуть запровадити санкції
проти Німеччини, наприклад, в сфері автомобілебудування.
І це те, чого ані німецька промисловість, ані німецька політика не можуть собі дозволити.
Нові санкції, які готуються проти "Північного потоку-2", ставлять Німеччину в глухий кут
і боляче вдарять по престижу країни, вважає експерт.
Якщо американські санкції призведуть до того, що проєкт доведеться зупинити, то гадаю, це буде
недуже хорошим сигналом для відродження трансатлантичної співпраці, якої нині очікують.
Адже США будуть втручатися в енергетичну політику такої вагомої європейської країни, як Німеччина.
Щодо газопроводу Eugal, сухопутного продовження "Північного потоку-2", то газ його першою ниткою
пішов вже на початку року, це необхідно для підтримання системи в робочому стані.
І "Газпром" оплачуватиме повністю заброньовані потужності трубопроводу незалежно від того,
скільки газу ним проходитиме. Потужності заброньовані на тривалий термін, і цей термін,
ймовірно, буде означати для "Газпрому" збитки.